(audience cheers and applauds)
Hi buddy, how are ya?
I have our cup, we are serving the angels.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Gosh, I don't have my cup, Rachael, I'm such a goober.
Ugh, it's somewhere.
I'll find it, maybe in the commercial break.
Guess what I was-
Oh my God, please, put that down, look at that haircut.
Put it down.
(audience laughs)
No, I don't mean to be creepy,
but this is what I was on my couch with,
and then eventually in bed with.
I couldn't put it down, and I just read it front to back,
it's all dogeared, and what I loved about this cookbook,
reading it last night, Rachael,
was how much I feel like no one is like you.
You talk about grabbing a handful as a measurement,
taking the stress out.
I think you're one of the most incredibly liberating,
and encouraging people to be freer in the kitchen.
You know, I never thought I would write a cookbook,
or be on television ever.
So, when I approached writing, it was always
from the point of view of the home cook,
not of the chef, or professional,
or aspiring to be anything other than hungry,
and making dinner.
I still write in the same manner, 26 books later.
And now, they're more like memoir mashups.
I just finished my 27th and delivered it in December.
It will be out next September.
And it's mostly essays and some recipes,
but I still write in the same manner
that I did all those years ago.
You have had such an incredible journey,
and you have accomplished so much in your life.
And I was wondering if you would take a trip
down memory lane with me,
and look at some milestones and memories.
I'm good with anything for you, buddy.
Okay, Let's take a look at Rachael Drew the Years.
(audience applauding)
Oh my gosh.
All right, 1968, Rachael was born on August 25th.
What are some of your very first memories
when you were a kid?
My very first memory is my mom
in the kitchen at the restaurant.
Our restaurant was called The Carvery,
and we were out in Cape Cod.
And I remember being on my mom's hip and she was fighting
with a purveyor on the phone, while she was heating
up all of the griddles and grills and cooktops,
and you know, she was turning everything on
in the restaurant.
And she went to hang up the phone, she put me down,
and I put my hand up to grab a spatula,
and I grilled my entire thumb
from here to here to the stove top.
(Drew shrieks)
And today, it's a darker color than the rest of my hand.
And that is literally my first memory in life,
griddling myself.
So it's kind of a "Harry Potter"-ish thing.
You know what I mean?
(audience laughing)
It's like, that certainly said what was born to be,
and what I've done with the whole rest of my 52 years.
I love that story so much.
Let's see which year we're going to next!
Oh gosh.
1982, You started working as a bus girl,
dishwasher, and fountain girl.
What did those jobs teach you,
and prepare you for the years to come?
Dish machine operator, not a very glamorous life.
A DMO, I was the DMO.
And when I got promoted to the fountain,
I thought my life would be amazing.
It was like "Cinderella,"
like, it was like being a prom queen,
to go to the fountain and get to wear a dress,
and waitress shoes instead of being
at this 120-degree dish machine,
buried in 3,000 dishes that smell like, you know,
eggs and hamburgers, it was just so exciting.
And then I realized that I was too short
to scoop the ice cream, and there was a little faucet
that would clean the scoops.
So it was a constant stream of leftover ice cream
on the side of the ice cream cooler.
So when I pushed myself up and throw myself,
hurl myself into the ice cream cooler to get the ice cream,
I ended up with a line of melted, sour,
every flavor that Howard Johnson served
of ice cream across my boobs.
(audience laughs)
So I became the girl with the ice cream boobs.
Not only was it worse than being at the dish machine,
but I was out in public, and I had a line across myself,
and I smelled.
So, thanks for bringing up some fun times.
(audience laughs)
We said last night, it was like you had two scoops and-
Yes, double, yes.
(audience laughs)
I also didn't anticipate, Rachael,
that I would be dressed like a soda jerk today,
so this is perfect.
(audience laughs)
(Rachael shrieks)
All right, let's see what's next.
You so are!
I really, I mean, okay.
1985!
You started your first business, called Delicious Liaisons,
while you were in high school.
What was it?
"Dangerous Liaisons" was a big movie,
a big, big stage production, big movie,
and great, great book and whatever.
So I thought Delicious Liaisons, what a fun name.
So I, just for fun, I made a fake catalog
of Delicious Liaisons gift baskets for people. (laughs)
And I showed it to my mother,
and she thought it was so delightful,
she took it down to the print shop,
and she had a bunch of these made up.
So I just started handing them out to random people
at the grocery store, at the pizza place,
in my class, give this to your mom or your dad.
And I started making baskets for sale.
It was just really an art project, but-
Well, and you know, the origin story of a pioneer.
Next, we are going to the year,
1997, you launched 30-Minute Meals.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Oh my gosh.
With local news station-
Yes, WRGB!
Oh, WRGB!
And you were in upstate New York.
What was the initial launch like?
My boss, who's one of my best friends to this day,
Donna Carnevale, we are, her birthday's this week,
by the way, happy birthday, Donna.
Happy birthday!
Yeah, we are super dear friends to this day.
Donna said, people love your food.
Why don't you just teach the class?
We had an idea to sell cooking classes,
and we made the mistake, as to real savvy business ladies,
to under-price the classes.
So when we went to ask chefs to teach the classes
that we were selling, so that we could sell more groceries,
we would have lost money rather than made.
So Donna said, well, you just teach the class.
I said, but Donna, I'm not a chef.
She said, who cares?
Everybody likes your food.
They buy it prepared in the case.
So, you teach them.
So the news station, WRGB, the world's first news station,
because it's the home of GE, General Electric.
It was literally the world's first television station.
They came to do a piece on us and our little class.
And it became a weekly segment,
and I would go to people's homes,
and firehouses, and police stations.
And I would teach literally anybody
who would let us in how to make a 30-minute meal.
That's that, it was a weird circumstance.
Well, I don't care about anyone's business prowess,
because you can't deny the power of 30-Minute Meals.
That's a billion-dollar idea.
It's so good.
(energetic upbeat music)
♪ Oh-oh (Oh-oh) ♪